hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast growth hormone and the
adult skeleton presented by dr. Nicholas
tree-toad i'm susie valdez elaborate and
all be your moderator for today's event
we're excited to bring you this
educational webcast
presented by labyrinth and sponsored by
da Sauron the Astoria is a global leader
in the fields of biotechnology with a
presence to over 80 countries for over
40 years
vo Sauron has been developing producing
and commercializing worldwide reagent
kits for a needy true diagnostic market
in particular for the amino Diagnostics
and an electro diagnostic segment dear
saurons products are specifically
designed for hospitals and private
testing laboratories their product menu
is unique for the weight and presence of
specialty tests which identified via
soaring as a diagnostic specialist the
more we make preparation about our
sponsor you can visit their website at
WWDC or calm before we begin I'd like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time during
the presentation just click on the green
Q&A button located at the lower left of
your presentation window and type your
question into the box that appears on
the screen we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation this is an
educational webinar and this offers free
continuing education credit after the
webinar is over please click on the CD
button located at the bottom left hand
corner of your webpage and follow the
process for obtaining those credits also
please notice that you will be reading
the presentation and slide window to
enlarge that window to click on the
screen icon located at the lower right
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
this presentation please click on the
one button at the top right of your
presentation window or use the Q&A
button and let us know you're having a
problem I'd now like to introduce our
fabulous speaker dr. Nicholas Trudeau's
dr. treatise is an associate professor
of medicine at Harvard Medical School
and the pituitary endocrinologist at
Massachusetts General Hospital in Boston
he's a graduate of the University of
decent Athens School of Medicine and
Harvard Medical School
he completed his centered residency in
internal medicine and fellowship
training in endocrinology as Beth Israel
Deaconess Medical Center at Boston he
has authored and co-authored over a
hundred and ten publications including
peer-reviewed articles and book chapters
in his field in stirrers as an associate
editor for the independence an editorial
board member for several independent and
a peer reviewer for numerous endocrine
and other medical journals please join
me in welcoming dr. Nicholas Treatise I
will now turn the presentation over to
him welcome sir
Thank You Sussie and welcome everyone
I'm dr. Nicholas readers it's my
pleasure for you to be here today the
title of my presentation is growth
hormone and the adult skeleton here's my
disclosure slide the objectives for this
presentation are to discuss the
physiology of growth hormone secretion
and the diagnosis of growth hormone
deficiency or excess in adults we view
the consequences of growth hormone
deficiency for the adult skeleton and
describe the Sequeira of growth hormone
excess from the adult skeleton here's
the outline of this presentation we will
start with a historic overview then
discuss growth hormone secretion and
action in brief proceed to the diagnosis
of growth hormone deficiency and growth
hormone excess in adults and larger is
known as acromegaly and then
view the sexual growth hormone on bone
tissue finally need to discussing the
consequences of growth hormone
deficiency and go home and access for
the adult skeleton so it was a 100 years
ago that Harvey Cushing the famous
neurosurgeon postulated the existence of
the growth promoting substance produced
by the pituitary and this was based on
clinical observations at that time
nothing was known about the twittery
physiology it took at least another 15
years to I will describe the existence
of a substance elaborated by the
pituitary gland that promotes growth
based on animal experiments and it was
not until 1944 when growth hormone was
isolated initially the bovine in
sequence and then in the 1950s and 60s
finally the human growth hormone was
isolated and characterized by Sakhalin
and 16 March Raven in 1958 was a pioneer
who isolated human growth hormone of
Calavera origin and reported successful
use to promote growth in a child with
good form and efficient more recently in
the late 1960s Harrison he described the
effects of growth hormone on the adult
skeleton based on experiments in eat
dogs
and then a decade later the confident
human growth hormone was reported and it
was expressed in bacteria at a time and
then finally it became available for
clinical use in identifying children and
then in 1996 it was finally FDA approved
and became available produced in adults
who are growth hormone deficient and the
advent of recombinant human growth
hormone was very fortunate because in
1985 and a very growth hormone which
removed from the market because of an
association between Calavera growth
hormone use and a very severe in
life-threatening illness called stop
disease let's talk about growth hormone
secretion in action growth hormone is a
191 amino acid single chain protein the
major growth learning species is 2015 of
thousands and accounts for about 25% of
growth hormone in circulation there are
several variants including 23,000
variant produced by alternate splicing
and other variants produced by the post
translational modifications growth
hormone is secreted by somatic cells in
the anterior pituitary in a pulsatile
manner as you can see in the slide in a
trigger on the Left panel you can see
that there is a limited number of growth
hormone pulses through the day mainly
during slow-wave sleep exercise also
promotes growth hormone secretion
fasting increases the amplitude and the
frequency of the pulses as you can see
on the right panel of the slide and
Uncle Tom secretion first blood life
that increases during adolescence that
he declines gradually but is still
present throughout the dult life and is
active as we will see so how does growth
hormone exert its actions
it binds the growth hormone receptor
which belongs to the cytokine receptor
superfamily the figure shows the growth
hormone molecule in blue it is nestled
between two chains of the cycle of a
growth hormone receptor shown in green
so the receptor is dimerized
before growth hormone binds sleep and
then the Septor signals by activating
injector and stat pathway including
multiple stat isoforms as shown on the
slide quite a few years ago now the
schemata leading hypothesis was
postulated which is now known to be true
of course and according to this
hypothesis there's another protein known
currently as insulin-like growth
factor-1 variety one which mediates many
of a growth hormone effects so good
hormone directly or indirectly promotes
or stable linear growth it also has
effects on carbohydrate fat and protein
metabolism it does have effect from the
skeleton throughout life as we will see
what about insulin-like growth factor-1
this is a single chain protein 70 amino
acids long 7.62 about once it is
expressed in many tissues including
muscle liver and bone and it has
paracrine or local effects but also has
endocrine effects as it circulates in
the blood circulating igf-1 is primarily
a hepatic origin and it is carried
mostly by several at least six binding
proteins it's among other things served
to prolong life and also modulated
actions in particular the majority of
circulating igf-1 is carried in the
ternary complex consisting of igf-1 I
tip binding protein tree and the acid we
label subunit secretion of igf-1 by the
liver is positively regulated by a
growth hormone and thus igf-1 levels in
the circulation serve as a good measure
of growth hormone action I think one
levels do not vary during the day and
are not affected by food consumption
until one levels do increase during
adolescence and then gradually decline
throughout life that were present in
active throughout the lifespan so let's
talk briefly about growth hormone
secretion and physiology on top here you
can see growth hormone and produced by
the pituitary gland and a growth hormone
secretion is stimulated that go home the
reason for one of the known as futile
age it is a colonic origin it is
inhibited by summer studying it is also
a autonomic origin there's also another
peptide
non masculine which is secreted
primarily on your stomach and stimulates
growth home secretion once calmly
secreted in the circulation
goes everywhere in the body through the
bloodstream and has multiple effects as
you can see on several issues including
an anabolic effect on bone muscle and
liver like political sex on top and also
contain chilling effect on several
issues including muscle and liver in the
liver and other tissues growth hormone
or stimulates igf-1 secretion which in
turn is multiple anabolic effect social
insulin like effects from glucose
homeostasis and of course igf-1 feeds
back on the hypothalamus and pituitary
to inhibit and control growth hormone
secretion in the classic negative
feedback link mechanism so um let's turn
our attention to growth hormone
deficiency in adults in adults growth
hormone deficiency is relatively
uncommon with an estimated prevalence of
to decree a person's by 10,000 even
general population it's important to
consider who is at risk for growth
hormone deficiency during adult life and
these are patients who have structural
on Twitter your hippo colonic lesions
such as tumors in the Catedral economies
patients wonder when to to very surgery
or radiation therapy traumatic brain
injury and subarachnoid hemorrhage
infection in the brain and that we are
including the colitis or meningitis in
rarely idiopathic growth hormone
deficiency of adult onset is possible
although the initial controversy in
addition growth hormone deficiency
negative childhood um origin onset and
in children it can be a consequence of
the structural lesions it can occur as a
result of genetic abnormalities that
really like oh god homing synthesis or
it can be the public it's like we don't
set upon deficiency may persist in adult
life in
subject of patience or it may result
particularly when we do plastic poison
show whether the features of adulthood
or immune deficiency these patients have
increased central adiposity primarily
abdominal and positive decreased muscle
mass they also have decreased bone mass
as we will see an increased fracture
risk cardiac function is impaired and as
a consequence their exercise capacity is
of them impaired they also may have
dyslipidemia higher cholesterol and
insulin resistance quality of life is
rotten impaired in these patients and
growth hormone replacement is often
beneficial in relating these creatures
of the about growth immune deficiency
syndrome although this reason it should
not be discussed at length
today so how to make the diagnosis of
growth hormone deficiency in adults an
important message is that measuring
growth hormone levels in adults in a
random manner is of no diagnostic value
and this is because growth hormone
levels fluctuate a lot during the day
in fact in healthy adults Montenegro
Trani levels are often undetectable and
through the course of the day so what
about igf-1 levels as I already
mentioned I different levels serve as a
good measure of growth hormone action
can we use them to make the diagnosis of
growth hormone deficiency
so here's slide and this slide shows
idh1 levels of patients with diagnosed
growth hormone deficiency
stratified by the range and white
triangles show men and build triangles
and show women and concede that younger
patients those who are below 40 years
old generally have no idea one level
below the normal range the normal range
is shown in dashed lines however older
patients particularly those in their 50s
60s and Beyond often have at least one
levels in the normal range
so the point is that measuring igf-1
levels or even IG f pg3 levels can be
helpful in the diagnosis of a quote on
efficiency in only in younger patients
however particularly among patients who
are over 40 up to 60% of these patients
make any normal age and gender adjusted
igf-1 levels in addition you need to
consider that igf-1 levels and below in
patients who have attraction reverser
during starvation and youth critical
illness liver disease cirrhosis
uncontrolled diabetes mellitus
hypothyroidism or women taking oral
estrogen containing contraceptives
however there is a subgroup of patients
in whom the diagnosis of adult code from
the deficiency can be made on the basis
of either one levels alone and these are
patients who have organically little
disease such as pituitary tumor and
equivocal II low serum igf-1 levels less
than two standard deviations below the
mean and known deficiency of three or
more additional people is a hormone or
munch besides growth hormone here are
the data the figure on the Left shows
you a group of them patients with
pituitary disease in their stratified by
the number of pituitary hormone
proficiencies available growth hormone
and what you can see here is the percent
of patients who are growth hormone
deficiency so stimulation testing you
can see from the slide that patients who
have three or four additional degree
very common proficiencies are 96% and
99% likely to be growth only deficient
on the right-hand side you can see the
igf-1 levels for patients between
between again stratified by the number
of additional crippling hormone
common efficiencies and in the left
patients our growth hormone deficient in
the right panel
patients are growth hormone sufficient
what you can see is that among the
patients who are growth hormone
sufficient and have three or four
additional people coordinate the
opposite none of these patients have no
idea one levels so again making the
point that in patients we have organic
pituitary disease knowledge upon levels
and three or four additional tutoring
deficiencies are extremely likely to
have got hormone deficiency in these
patients do not need any additional
testing however the rest of the patients
we need stimulation testing in order to
establish the diagnosis to go to on the
deficiency the preview on the light of
the slide shows you how on these results
look like particularly the insect in a
small figure shows the growth hormone
levels in a population of them public
subject in growth hormone deficient
adults after the administration of
insulin including of course in cause
hypoglycemia if given in doses it's
sufficient dosage and in healthy
individuals you can see that insulin in
this paper glycaemia induces a rapidly
growth hormone secretion in contrast
patients record on addition show no
growth hormone secretion after insulin
administration the left side of the
creature shows you the people growth
hormone levels achieved of the
instrument stimulation of the controls
almost always showing is response and
patients with their reputation who like
growth hormone show little or no
response so you control a line between
three and five nanograms
now that nicely distinguishes patients
are sufficient in patients will go drama
division so insulin tolerance test is
still the traditional gold standard for
the diagnostic growth hormone deficiency
in adult life and it's also used in
children by the way
however the Questacon pleasant
hypoglycemia is unpleasant in carry some
risk particularly in older patients
patients with heart disease or seizures
and it's contraindicated in a population
and for this reason the tapping other
tests that we developed that involve the
administration of growth hormone
releasing hormone GLH together arginine
arginine alone or glucagon along as
stimulation growth hormone secretion and
this video shows you the diagnostic cut
points recommended by different society
guidelines growth hormone research
society American Association of Clinical
Endocrinology and Endocrine Society
different times they have done issued
guidelines about the diagnostic cut
points from advisable to make the
diagnosis of growth hormone deficiency
and as you can see that the diagnostic
cut points vary between tests and they
are becoming also somewhat more
stringent over time it has now learned
that in particular got horny secretion
varies depending on body adiposity
and particularly after undulates and
arginine administration and as a
consequence the diagnostic cut points or
goat immune deficiency are now dependent
on body mass index or BMI after growth
hormone releasing hormone energy in
administration in addition recent data
suggests that glucagon administration
also may fail to elicit growth hormone
secretion in obese or overweight
individuals in fat gain and study that
was published recently forty five
percent out of forty seven healthy
control subjects were overweight or
these fail to glucose regulation best
using a car pointer
nanograms per ml in this population a
lower point of 100 per ml is apprised
and fiscal points can also be an asset
dependent and too short
so in summary testing for optimal
efficiency should be limited only to
patients at risk ladies condition the
diagnostic or medications in adults
generally require simulation testing
however circulating igf-1 levels can be
diagnostic in some patients let's talk
about growth hormone excess in adults
also known as acromegaly this condition
is fairly rare the Presidential forty to
eighty six cases the Libyan population
and an annual incidence of four cases
per million it is course almost always
by a benign to very adenoma that
secretes growth hormone in an
unregulated manner and as you can see it
can cause bony abnormalities the
pictures are on Oprah is very famous
patient it was in but Harvey Cushing's
first the patient is automatically on
the run-up to the surgery by crushing
you can see the patient before and after
the diagnosis Ibaka mentally there
evident only abnormalities weakening of
the nose and lips with broadening of the
jaw and enlargement of the hands in
addition mechanically causes multiple
manifestations including headaches high
blood pressure diabetes mellitus heart
disease congestive heart failure sleep
apnea and colon polyps
menstrual irregularity source the
arthritis and asthma disease associated
with increased risk of vertebral
fractures of the condom syndrome and if
left untreated or partly treated
grammatical is associated with decreased
life expectancy of the average by ten
years so it is important agnostic early
so how to make the diagnosis so first of
all single measurement of circulating
growth hormone is not accurate
since growth hormone secretion is also
tile
however randomly measured growth hormone
levels that are extremely low below zero
point three nanotubes Bernal practically
excludes the diagnosis more useful in
practice is the so called oral
glucose-tolerance test during this test
growth hormone levels are measured every
30 minutes for two hours after
administration of Seneca grams of
glucose in patients with acromegaly
generally will fail suppress growth
hormone levels below one nanogram per ml
after the oral glucose administration be
precise diagnostic a point again may
vary between assays and has become more
stringent over time largely because of
the availability of more sensitive
assays so this is a helpful test to
confirm the diagnosis electronically but
about igf-1 levels this correlates very
well with clinical manifestations of
acromegaly and measuring 90th one is an
accurate test for the diagnostic
remodeling if measured in a well
validated assay and this one levels are
stable during the day and are not
technically videos however the assay is
technically difficult it requires
stripping the igf-1 of the binding
proteins in circulation in the past some
of the assays been what use recombinant
reference standards and because I think
one varies with age they said we need a
large age stratified one of the database
to accurate best interpretation in
addition lower geophone levels can be
seen in patients or starving critically
ill patients with anorexia nervosa
chronic liver disease women oral
contraceptives or patients with quality
control diabetes and these conditions
can confound the findings of the igf-1
assay so in summary randomly measured
growth hormone levels are a little
diagnostic value however measuring on
circulating igf-1 levels provide an
accurate
domestic test at the RSA is technically
difficult intelligent any pitfalls
Arkansas measuring growth only levels of
glucose administration is very helpful
in confirming the diagnosis
electronically so let's turn our
attention to the code culminate that
bond and I will start by reminding write
designing um what looks like so this
figure shows you the long bone looks
like on the left femur and in the right
flat bones that comes from the cow
and in both cases and bone is composed
of a compact also known as cortical
layer that surrounds a core of the
sponge for bone of a known as trabecular
or cancellous bone in these types of a
bone tissue they respond differently to
in the continue life so it's important
to keep in mind through our discussion
at the microscopic level on bone tissue
only has a limited number of cells
including osteoblasts that lay down bone
matrix and calcify bone or suicide a
very important containing bone and
osteoclasts that we shortfall that
exponentially am a cycle of bone
remodeling take place as you can see on
the left side of the panel that was the
class that derived from stem cells of
one side lineage and those and assured
bone and after the bones resort then
osteoblasts that are that come from a
different stem cell population you can
actually be laying down bone matrix that
becomes calcified and osteoblasts are
then become both the sides that have
trapped inside the bone matrix are
important in maintaining the bone in
this cycle bone remodeling also known as
bone turnover is essential for many
processes including bone repair another
others and this is a process that is a
very much dependent on endocrine stimuli
including growth hormone
so it shows you a summary of findings of
them in vitro experiments and also
studies from animals that highlight the
effects of growth hormone and other
hormones on the skeleton on different
cell populations to see the growth
hormone from the pituitary and directly
go from stimulates or stabilize the
differentiation and bond formation
in addition growth hormone and insulin
secretion by the liver it also leads to
a g1 secretion the mostly blasts other
forming shorter stimulate the
osteoblasts through both loops igf-1
including parathyroid hormone estrogen
in thyroid hormone and other growth
factors and both the locally secreted
igf-1 in the endocrine I just want them
stimulate bone formation they also
reduce rank ligand which in turn
stimulates osteoclasts to a lesion or
bone also even severe growth hormone and
igf-1 have direct effects on the growth
plate and for the purposes of children
and adolescents and promote in the
control confirmation and ossification
that's responsible for being a goat to a
child with enough lessons so in summary
and growth hormone igf-1 system promotes
both conformation and bone disruption
throughout life again in summary and
gourmandises one stimulated in your own
growth during childhood another
since biography concealed carbonate also
known as growth rate growth hormone
stimulates or stabilizing
differentiation and I just want created
by osteoblasts stimulates for
information but also invade the
synthesis of rank ligand which in turn
stimulates osteoblast differentiation
and function and grass growth 191
promote bone turnover including both
conformation and desorption so then what
are the consequences of growth hormone
deficiency will be adult skeleton so
patients who are lacking growth hormone
during adult life has decreased bone
turnover including both decreased
confirmation and resorption and this can
be substantiated both by bone biopsy and
some automatic studies and also by
measuring markers or bone turnover in
the circulation as a consequence of the
decreased bone turnover adults with
growth hormone deficiencies have
decreased bone mass measured in vivo as
born in neural density most commonly
using dual energy x-ray absorptiometry
be also known as DEXA and the figure
shows a decline in from one study of 26
and treated about dongsik patients with
growth hormone efficiency will show
decreased bone density in the lumbar
spine
the middle column measured by exome and
also in the lumbar spine income bone
density decreased measured by ethnicity
this is qualitative computer tomography
and cortical bone density is also
decreased in the forearm in these
patients measured by a single
partnership geometry and you can see
tradition for the medians for bone
density compared to the general
population
and importantly a marker code column
doing adult life is associated with
increased accuracy you can see that
these are a publication should three
different studies three different
countries in patients who were on growth
hormone patient during adult life or
compared either
to the general population or other
pituitary patient without quote from
efficiency and in all cases the risk of
fracture you're significantly higher in
patients with coronary ssin see compared
to the control population so the gods
ground effective go home replacement in
adults well we have studies now that
show that replacing growth hormone in an
adult population increases bone density
after the treatment period of at least
12 and preferably 18 months the figure
shows the findings randomized clinical
trial during which thirty two men with
Gautama deficiency will randomly
allocated to either growth hormone or
placebo and you can see that in the
anteroposterior spine bone density
increased by about close to six percent
after 18 months controls showed mineral
change
lateral spine of the showed similar
increase in density control showed
slight decline femoral neck ocean on
patients with growth hormone deficiency
receiving growth hormone replacement or
showed an increase about three percent
again the controls around shows slight
decline bone density but they would not
change in the radiation around
increasing bone density showing that the
gum exocrine replacement are specific to
different types of bones
the net analysis of randomized clinical
trials report on replacement in about
potentially subserve Asians I mean
showing that effects across from
replacement on bone density is really
dependent on the duration of growth
hormone replacement the other panel
shows some studies that are up to 12
months in duration and in particular the
trigger shows the difference between
growth hormone and possible colonization
bone density in the number spine and you
can see that most of the studies are
centered around zero and the diamond is
assembly effective in fact centered at
zero the p value is zero point seven
zero three so clearly not physically
significant so growth hormone
replacement for twelve months
optical month and the average is no
effect on bone density however studies
exceeding this duration typically 18 to
24 months show an increase of bone
density in response to growth on
immigration and as you can see the
p-value is zero point zero 21 which is
the physical significance in the second
environment on this is the summary exact
clearly shows an increase in bone
density and after go from replacement
what about long term that's a quote on
replacement here are data from Sweden
study extending over 15 years on the
Left panel shows the effects of growth
hormone replacement of the lumbar spine
on men versus women men show an increase
in bone density up to 10 percent after
15 years the women the magnitude of
equipment is much smaller and the social
transient as you can see similarly in
the femoral neck men appear to show a
greater benefit in bone density and done
and this is an observation that has been
made on in other studies as well let's
talk briefly about the effects of growth
from replacement in young adults who
have childhood onset and growth hormone
deficiency that persists during adult
life most of these studies find that
these young adults who have completed
their linear growth and are still go
from deficient may benefit from growth
hormone replacement and for several
years in order to optimize the peak bone
mass you can see here that three other
core studies show p-values that are
significant they show between create 3.9
percent increase in bone density in the
lumbar spine after work on replacement
discovered receivables and as a
consequence has been recommended that
young adults with persistent or home
deficiency of childhood onset should be
offered good on replacement during a
young adult life at least with early
twenties in order to optimize their peak
bone mass without on the risk of
fracture and the effects of growth
hormone replacement on this elevated
fracture risk unfortunately we have no
data from clinical trials however we
believe observational data if they I'm
showing you training for the negotiation
of study of over 8,000 adults and growth
from the replacement and over 1200
adults were replaced this could also go
from deficiency that did not receive
growth hormone replacement they did
follows over a period of four to six
years in a surveillance database and you
can see that the trustor incidence in
patients will be received on replacement
was much lower than among those who is
not received from a replacement
suggesting that growth hormone
replacement is associated with a lower
fracture risk in fact on Cox
proportional hazards analysis school
from the placement which protected from
instant action with a hazard ratio of
0.6 88 that will succed exclusive
after adjusting for multiple potential
confounders to examine three dead growth
hormone deficiencies associated with
decreased bone mineral density and
increased calculus with adults growth
hormone replacement includes bone
mineral density without the effect cream
greater in men the women of the
treatment period of at least 12 to 18
months and growth in placement appears
mitigate the increased actually screen
adults based on observational data that
no clinical trials are available in
fracture endpoints shut down the
external attention to brought home an
exception adults also known as
iconically and this equality for the
adults telethon a meta-analysis which
published recently that really outlines
the effects that is known about the
effects of growth on accession the adult
skeleton this net analysis included 41
studies and over over 1900 patients with
a Canadian controls and priming some of
them of these studies we indicate that
patient we technically have increased
bone formation and resorption that is
increased bone turnover based on the on
on biomarkers measured in the
circulation and these included Co
cousing organ specific alkyl phosphatase
as leadership on information and then
come other biomarkers such as hearing
and collagen modified serve as measures
of bone breakdown the desired role
increased in patients with acromegaly
most patients with acromegaly who have
done normal testosterone or estrogen
levels depending on gender have normal
bone density the number spine and
actually somewhat higher bone density
the emerald neck however patients who
have hypogonadism
both men and women has decreased bone
density in the lumbar spine in the
femoral neck in furthermore patients
with acromegaly as a group have been
increased the people fracture risk with
an odds ratio of a
22:26 the previous year shows on the
subgroup analysis patients with connect
illegal in the top panel stratify
patients with acromegaly telling the
presence of active disease or controlled
entities and after treatment
electronically because you see
themselves in the panel on the right
that shows you that patients with active
disease is significantly increased risk
of vertebral fractures with an odds
ratio of 3.3 the middle panel stratify
patients with acromegaly by gender and
shows you that men have a higher or
greater than women or having vertebral
fracture in that auto issue is 2.19 and
then the bottom panel stratify patients
by cannot establish a patient with
hypogonadism and low testosterone or
women with low estrogen at higher risk
with an odds ratio of 1.68 obviously a
higher risk of the rebuild fracture so
in summary growth hormone excess in
adults leads to increased bone turnover
doubts
we've got home in excess generally have
the bone mineral density that is normal
however some people these patients who
have hypogonadism have low bone density
and currently associated with increased
risk of early Brown fracture so what are
the major points that I'd like you to
take home growth hormone and igf-1 and
important actions from skeleton
throughout their lives
and stimulate both bond formation and
resorption the diagnosis of Cortona
deficiency in adults generally require
stimulation testing the diagnosed with
acromegaly
behind as growth hormone exciting adults
relies on igf-1 levels and can also be
confirmed by measuring growth hormone
the glucose administration in about lack
of growth hormones associated with
decreased bone mineral density and
increased fracture risk which may be
mitigated by growth hormone replacement
acromegaly is associated with increased
fatigue load fracture risk we still have
done work to do in particular an
activity into the better utilization
particular assay organization improving
both the growth hormone igf-1 assays
ideally should be harmonized I'm sure
that they're comparable across different
platforms use of international
recombinant reference standards has been
recommended ideally you believe that
randomized clinical trials in order to
definitively establish a beneficial
effect of Gotham regulation about
particular skin as however if such
studies will be difficult poppy seeds
and growth normally come this early
approve any social group in Europe a PMA
adults and finally you need to
understand what are the consequences of
achieving control of acromegaly and
control of growth hormone excess in the
adult skeleton so will be some thoughts
and I would like to end the presentation
and a copy and to answer any questions
and I would like to thank you for your
kind attention doctor treaters thank you
so much for that informative
presentation it's now time for Q&A if
you have any questions you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on that need to date button
on the lower left
sorry about that there's a grandfather
clock on the lower left of your
presentation window and type in those
questions into the box that appears on
the screen and click the send button
well insert of many questions as we have
time for if we're unable to get to those
questions
dr. trios will follow up via email after
the presentation so let's take a look at
our first audience member questions
looks like we have several coming in dr.
tuder's how would you evaluate an adult
patient with an abnormal high or low
igf-1 level yes thank you this is an
interesting and important question I
first recommend repeating the igf-1
level because particularly some assays
may lack sufficient precision so it's
always really important to repeat the
test to be sure that it is the finding
is consistent it is also very important
to understand the context in which the
test is obtained what was the reason and
there has to be clinical suspicion of
growth hormone excess or deficiency so
the clinical context is very important
as I also mentioned earlier on igf-1
levels are very much dependent on age
should making sure that they are
inappropriate on age-adjusted
normal if database has been used it's
essential please keep in mind that I GF
on levels are affected by other factors
besides growth hormone and this include
starvation anorexia nervosa cirrhosis
severe liver disease that is and
critical illness uncontrolled diabetes
mellitus oral contraceptive using women
all these factors can lower igf-1
in contrast igf-1 levels are higher in
lessons or during pregnancy sometimes in
patients with cortical access so knowing
all these factors are very important in
interpreting the results after these are
considered then we ought to think
whether an idea on level that it
represent it is indicative over
acromegaly if well chronically is
clinically suspected then the igf-1
level is elevated then I would proceed
with both hormones on suppression test
that is a liquor store instead in order
to confirm the diagnosis electronically
and then image the patient with a
computer MRI or proceeding treatment
plans on the other hand if the igf-1 is
low in this clinical suspicion of growth
hormone deficiency that is the patient
is at risk or growth hormone deficiency
then I consider whether the patient has
other different hormone deficiencies
that would enable me to make a diagnosis
that go communication cratering network
life even without the stimulation test
if a patient has three or more
additional deficiencies they have
organic and pituitary disease then
ontology unlevel is diagnostic of growth
hormone deficiency otherwise I would do
a growth hormone stimulation test and
classically this essentially tolerance
test but today we all can do a glucagon
stimulation test and because insulin is
unpleasant and can be hazardous run
particularly for all the people or
patients with heart disease or seizures
is actually contraindicated
thank you for that response
dr. Trias you have a time for a couple
more here's our next question very
interesting is there a difference in
bone density response to growth hormone
replacement between men and women thank
you for this question this is actually a
very interesting and important question
indeed among several if not most studies
of growth hormone replacement in adults
with
gautama deficiency there is a there
appears to be a difference that is men
appear to show a greater improvement in
bone density compared to women and in
some cases it is possible or even likely
that women may clean undertreated
particularly women taking oral
contraceptives require higher dose of
growth hormone in order to achieve
similar on igf-1 patient however even in
some studies women have been adequately
treated there appears to be a lesser
response with regards to bone density
after growth hormone replacement so this
appears to be a true biological
phenomenon over but still somewhat
controversial and we're still trying to
understand the fundamental basis for
this it doesn't mean that women should
not be treated of course but it has to
be very careful to optimize the
treatment dose in order to try to
maximize the benefits in the population
response as well we have time for one
more question before we end today here's
one from the audience number do we know
why patients with a Q melody appear to
be at increased vertebral side a
vertical fracture risk despite having
normal bone density thank you um this is
also an interesting question indeed
patients with acromegaly are at
increased risk of a debug fractures even
though they have normal bone density and
this appears to be paradoxical however
we now know that bone density is only
one of the determinants of bone strength
bone density does not measure for
example on quality in fact there are now
data suggesting that bone
microarchitecture that is the fine
structure of bone is impaired in many
patients with acromegaly and this may be
partly at least an explanation for the
increased in our factory expectations
with acromegaly it's a very interesting
question and has just began to learn
about why this is happening but clearly
more research is needed in order to
really understand this issue thank you
thank you doctor treatise and thank you
again for your wonderful and informative
presentation do you have any final
comments you'd like to share with
audience before we close today well I
would like to thank you as well as the
audience for their participation and
hope that this activity has been
informative highlight some of the key
issues pertaining to the effects of
growth hormone and the skeleton in a
look forward claiming additional
questions or comments cutting ahead
thank you so much and thank you again
dr. Treves and I'd also like I think
elaborate and Dia Soren for making
today's educational webcast possible
before we go I want to let everyone know
that today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing through December
15 2017 you will receive an email from
Roberts whether you know Willner webcast
will be available for replay please
share that announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event that's all for now
thanks for joining us and we hope to see
you again soon buh-bye